А зараз - «heute journal»
з Ханною Ціммерман і Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Доброго вечора всім.
Тепер вже ніхто не
зможе сказати: «Ми цього не знали,
ми не бачили, що ця біда вже насувається».
Найважливіший експортний товар України
не може потрапити на світовий ринок,
тому що Росія блокує доступ до українських портів.
Пшениця, кукурудза, олійні культури -
продукти харчування, необхідні для мільйонів людей,
особливо в бідних регіонах світу, заблоковані.
Експерти переконані - якщо нічого не вдіяти,
то світу загрожує найбільший голод з часів Другої світової війни.
Тому необхідно щось вдіяти.
Війна проти України перетворюється також
і в зернову війну проти всього світу.
Далі - Андреас Кюнаст.
На відео ми бачимо нескінченний конвой вантажівок,
позначених літерою Z.
За даними українських ЗМІ,
конвой знімали в Маріуполі,
задокументувавши, як Росія
вивозить українське зерно до Криму.
За словами українців, це безпрецедентна широкомасштабна крадіжка.
І вона може бути ще одним доказом того,
що міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини
називає зерновою війною
і що є свідомою воєнною стратегією Путіна.
Тому що він цілеспрямовано
нищить українські зерносховища,
бомбардує поля, руйнує шляхи поставок
та свідомо блокує порти,
через які Україна могла б експортувати зерно.
Військово-морський флот Росії блокує українські порти
від Маріуполя до Одеси,
не даючи вийти 57 суднам, завантаженим зерном.
На борту - 1,25 млн тонн пшениці.
Увесь світ повинен хвилюватися.
Як представниця країни, яка головує у G7,
міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини Бербок
минулого тижня закликала до дій
міністрів закордонних справ країн G7,
а сьогодні - міністерка розвитку Шульце
з таким самим закликом звернулася до міністрів розвитку країн G7.
Якщо ми нічого не вдіємо, у світі настане найбільший голод
з часів Другої світової війни.
До війни Україна кожного місяця експортувала
до 6 млн тонн зерна та олійних культур.
Через російську блокаду зараз вдається
експортувати лише 200 000 тонн.
І це удар не тільки для України.
Без нашого експорту зерна у десятках країн вже зараз
не вистачає продуктів харчування.
І з часом ситуація
може стати відверто жахливою.
Ускладнює ситуацію ще й найгірша за останні десятиліття
посуха в Східній Африці, а також те,
що через аномальну спеку в країні
Індія заборонила експорт пшениці,
а Росія, крадучи зерно,
водночас намагається звинуватити в голоді країни Заходу.
Таку глобальну кризу спричиняють саме санкції,
авторами яких керують надмірні амбіції
та русофобія.
Захід шукає нові шляхи для експорту українського зерна.
Це можуть бути внутрішні водні шляхи до країн Балтії
або ж - географічно найближче рішення
- залізничні шляхи до Румунії.
Проте цього не достатньо, щоб доставити
ту кількість зерна, яка нам потрібна
і яку Україна може продати.
15 хв тому міністерка закордонних справ Бербок
прибула до Нью-Йорку.
Занепокоєння через зернову кризу вже дійшло до ООН,
адже йдеться про життя мільйонів людей.
Цікаво те, що одна країна має зиск від продажу пшениці,
яка так різко зросла в ціні.
І це - Росія.
«Скоро зустрінемося,
Фінляндіє та Швеціє, можете розраховувати на нашу підтримку»,
заявила сьогодні міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини.
Німеччина за рекордний час дала зелене світло
для такого переломного моменту
в західному оборонному альянсі.
Прийняття Швеції та Фінляндії тепер повинне
відбутися якнайшвидше.
Інші 29 країн НАТО також повинні дати згоду.
І лише одна з них, Туреччина, виступає проти.
Міністр закордонних справ цієї країни
сьогодні перебуває з візитом у свого візаві в США,
тому що, по-перше, останній хоче зрозуміти,
чого насправді прагне Туреччина -
зупинити розширення НАТО на північ?
Чи, можливо, використати цю ситуацію в своїх цілях
і задовольнити власних виборців?
А по-друге, тому що сьогодні така проблема в НАТО
є для США вкрай небажаною.
Поговоримо з нашим кореспондентом у США
Ельмаром Тевесеном.
Ельмаре, у якій атмосфері відбувалася ця розмова?
За тим, що ми бачили, можемо сказати,
що атмосфера була дуже дружньою.
Міністр закордонних справ Туреччини та його американський візаві
зверталися один до одного за іменем - «Тоні» та «Мевлют».
Міністр закордонних справ Туреччини чітко заявив,
що його країна дотримується того ж принципу, що й США,
а саме - відкривати двері всім, хто хоче вступити до НАТО.
Проте, з одного боку, у Туреччини, за його словами,
є побоювання щодо безпеки,
а з іншого боку, Чавушоглу зазначив,
що Швеція декілька років тому
припинила поставки озброєння до Туреччини.
Загалом склалося враження,
що вони шукають
поле для компромісу.
Розмова була дуже дружньою.
На мою думку, метою Ентоні Блінкена
було насамперед показати,
що США готові вислухати побоювання Туреччини.
Чи означає це, що США налаштовані оптимістично
щодо майбутнього рішення Туреччини?
Так, тому що вони розуміють,
про що саме йдеться.
А йдеться про поставку пакетів модернізації
для винищувачів F-16, які має Туреччина.
А, можливо, навіть і про поставку 40 нових винищувачів типу F-16.
Це б коштувало США 6 млрд доларів,
тому Джо Байдену було б дуже важко
досягти схвалення таких поставок Конгресом.
Проте щодо пакетів модернізації,
то тут країни могли б досягти компромісу.
За словами міністерки закордонних справ Німеччини Анналени Бербок,
у цій кризі кожному слід добре усвідомити свою відповідальність
і подумати, як краще вчинити.
Я вважаю, що і в Німеччині,
і в США налаштовані на те,
що рішення цієї проблеми буде знайдено.
Дякую, Ельмаре.
А тепер поговоримо з Йорґом Бразе, який зараз в Туреччині.
Щодо причин: офіційно Туреччина відмовляється підтримувати
Фінляндію та Швецію через курдів.
Чи є це справжньою та єдиною причиною?
Деякі, звичайно, вважають,
що йдеться про внутрішньополітичні причини.
Наступного року в Туреччині відбуватимуться вибори президента.
Через складну економічну ситуацію рівень підтримки
президента Ердогана є дуже низьким.
А такою сильною політичною позицією
він міг би привабити
свій ісламсько-консервативний електорат.
Але, на мій погляд,
такі припущення є занадто поверхневими.
Справа в тому, що, на думку Туреччини, інші члени НАТО
приділяють недостатньо уваги
питанню її безпеки.
Боротьба з тероризмом партії РКК є національною метою Туреччини.
І, незалежно від того, яка партія стоїть на чолі уряду,
вона продовжуватиме цю боротьбу, водночас маючи підтримку населення.
Туреччина не відчуває достатньо підтримки від Заходу.
Навпаки -
вона почувається навіть покараною.
Прикладом є введення військ Туреччини
у Північну Сирію 2019-го року через тамтешніх представників РКК.
Тоді курдські збройні формування були союзниками США
у війні проти «Ісламської держави» на Півночі Сирії.
Тому зокрема Швеція ввела ембарго, про яке говорилось раніше.
І зараз Анкара не може погодитись
на вступ до НАТО країни, яка нібито й досі постачає зброю
курдським збройним формуванням YPG.
Ми щойно почули, що США вірять у вдале вирішення цього питання.
А як щодо турецького уряду?
Сьогодні як міністр закордонних справ,
так і радник президента Ердогана сказали,
що Туреччині потрібні суттєві гарантії безпеки.
Вони хочуть бачити чіткі кроки, які показують,
що питання безпеки Туреччини сприймається серйозно.
Це може стосуватися кількох пунктів:
наприклад, Туреччина вимагає від Швеції
екстрадиції 30 осіб, які нібито підтримують терористів.
Крім того, вона може вимагати,
щоб Швеція скасувала ембарго на поставки зброї.
У будь-якому випадку Туреччина хоче бути впевненою,
що Швеція та Фінляндія будуть вживати
більш рішучих заходів для протидії РКК та YPG.
Дуже цікаво, дякую.
Перейдімо до нашої наступної теми:
Європа ще дуже багато має зробити,
щоб досягти поставлених цілей щодо захисту клімату.
Ускладнює ситуацію ще й необхідність
якомога швидше
стати енергетично незалежною від Росії.
Європейська комісія сьогодні представила
свій план щодо цього на найближчі роки.
На його реалізацію потрібні мільярди.
І значна його частина пов'язана з морем.
Майже 40 років тому в Німеччині з'явилися
перші вітряні парки, як-от у землі Шлезвіґ-Гольштейн.
З вітряками, потужність яких сягала в середньому 50 кВт.
Потужність сучасних вітрових турбін
складає 4000 КВт, у 80 разів більше.
З одного боку, вони стали ефективнішими,
але з іншого - вищими.
Їхня висота сягає 260 метрів
від поверхні води до кінця лопаті ротора.
Угорі вітер дме сильніше і рівномірніше,
ніж біля поверхні землі.
Окрім цього, на більшій висоті літає менше птахів.
Один такий офшорний вітровий генератор може
забезпечити електроенергією до 16 000 господарств.
Таке джерело енергії потрібне Європі.
Офіційне гасло Брюсселя: «REPower EU».
Більше - у сюжеті Анне Ґалінек.
Кожна вітрова турбіна в Північному морі -
це крок до незалежності
від Володимира Путіна.
Такою сьогодні була одна з заяв Комісії ЄС
і вона чудово підходить до теми саміту
з питань вітроенергетики в Есб'єрзі,
куди данський уряд запросив
канцлера Німеччини й президентку Єврокомісії.
ЄС голосив у Брюсселі грандіозні плани:
у майбутньому частка європейської енергії,
яка надходить з відновлюваних джерел,
має складати вже 45% замість запланованих 40%.
Це означає розбудову системи вітроенергетики та
впровадження обов'язку встановлювати
сонячні батареї на покрівлях:
з 2026 року для промислових новобудов,
а з 2029 року - для приватних будинків.
Усе це буде можливо втілити, якщо
спростять процедури отримання дозволів
на встановлення вітрових електростанцій і
сонячних панелей.
ЄС вважає, що для переходу на вітрові турбіни
ще необхідно в середньому 9 років.
Єврокомісія має на увазі також і Берлін.
Звісно, «швидко» означає,
що перехід триватиме ще 2-3 роки.
Це максимально можлива швидкість,
оскільки станції необхідно замовити, виготовити,
завезти й встановити.
Ми робимо зараз все так швидко, як це можливо.
Найкраща енергія - це та, яку можна заощадити.
Так вважає Комісар з питань клімату
Франс Тіммерманс.
Проте він не планує вказувати європейцям,
як заощаджувати енергію.
Комісія не наважилася додати в план
обмеження швидкості.
«Хоча це було б найпростішим рішенням», -
так вважає Міністр енергетики Люксембургу.
Знизити ліміт швидкості на європейських
магістралях з 130 до 120 км/год
означало б заощадити пів мільйона барелів.
2 дні роботи з дому - це ще пів мільйона.
Таких заощаджень вистачило б,
щоб знизити ціни на нафту в усьому світі.
І я вважаю, це, справді, не зашкодило б.
У третій частині пакету
йдеться про енергопостачання за межами Росії.
Комісія пропонує спільну закупівлю
зрідженого газу й водню.
За схожим принципом купували вакцини.
Європі буде потрібно 300 млрд євро
на фінансування зміни енергетичної політики.
Кажуть, гроші на це братимуть з бюджету ЄС
і надходжень з торгівлі сертифікатами на викиди,
принаймні наразі.
Чи вистачить цих коштів - точно не може сказати
навіть Комісар з питань клімату.
Рано чи пізно настане момент,
коли нам треба буде проаналізувати
фінансову ситуацію в Європі загалом,
як це було під час пандемії Covid-19.
Перед нами постане питання:
чи вистачить нам грошей,
щоб профінансувати всі наші плани.
На саміті з питань вітроенергетики в Есб'єрзі
представники Нідерландів, Німеччини,
Данії й Бельгії ухвалили,
що в майбутньому країни об'єднають зусилля
у сфері вітроенергетики.
Заява Брюсселя дійшла й сюди.
Зараз ідеться про те,
чи отримають плани Комісії схвалення
з боку решти країн Європи.
У сюжеті «heute journal up:date» на цю тему
буде детальне обговорення,
в якому братиме участь технічний директор
енергопостачальної компанії «EWE», який вважає,
що в питанні розбудови системи енергопостачання
з відновлювальних джерел, зокрема в Німеччині,
існує проблема, пов'язана не з ухваленням рішень,
а радше з їхньою реалізацією.
А тепер знову до ситуації в Україні.
З заблокованого металургійного заводу «Азовсталь»
у Маріуполі, ймовірно,
ще сотні українських воїнів здалися в полон.
Їхня доля невідома.
За словами проросійських сепаратистів,
на металургійному заводі
ще перебувають інші солдати.
Тим часом у Києві триває перший судовий розгляд
справи про воєнний злочин,
який вчинив російський солдат.
21-річний обвинувачений визнав вину
у розстрілі беззбройної цивільної особи.
Солдатові загрожує довічне ув'язнення.
За даними ООН, зміна клімату
активно набирає обертів.
Останні 7 років були найтеплішими
в історії метеорологічних досліджень.
Про це йдеться в новому звіті про зміни клімату
Всесвітньої метеорологічної організації.
Концентрація парникових газів
в атмосфері вже 2020 року
перевищувала доіндустріальний рівень на 149%.
Темпи підвищення рівня моря наразі
становлять 4,5 мм на рік -
це вдвічі більше, ніж лише кілька років тому.
Окрім цього, рівень температури й кислотності
океанічних вод щороку зростає,
тому вони дедалі менше
зв'язують надлишкові молекули CO2.
Міністр охорони здоров'я Німеччини Лаутербах
надав план боротьби
з пандемією цьогорічної осені.
Згідно з ним, усі громадяни
мають отримати можливість
зробити щеплення від вірусу четвертою дозою.
Щоб реалізувати цей план,
уряд Німеччини планує замовити
додаткові вакцини проти коронавірусу.
Попередньо, вони будуть ефективними
проти різних штамів вірусу, як-от Дельта й Омікрон
або комбінацій кількох варіантів.
Лаутербах також повідомив про те,
що центри вакцинації продовжують працювати.
Бундестаг сьогодні великий, як ніколи.
Щоб значно зменшити його,
депутати «світлофорної» коаліції
надали нову пропозицію
щодо виборчої реформи.
Вона передбачає скасування
так званих «додаткових»
і «компенсаційних» мандатів.
У такому разі перемога у виборчому окрузі
не гарантуватиме місце в Бундестазі.
Критику щодо пропозиції
висловлює Союз CDU/CSU,
адже, ймовірно, від нових
правил постраждав би саме він.
Депутат від CSU Фрізер наголосив на можливому
«знеціненні ідеї виборчих округів
і головних компонентів демократії».
Упродовж кількох років партії
сперечаються щодо реформи виборчого права,
яка мала б скоротити чисельність Бундестагу.
Згідно з пропозицією «світлофорної» коаліції,
ексканцлера Герхарда Шредера
необхідно позбавити більшості його привілеїв,
як-от офісу і його співробітників.
Як причину зазначають, що
Шредер більше не бере на себе жодних зобов’язань
з посади колишнього канцлера.
Критика Шредера посилюється
і в Європейському парламенті.
У проєкті резолюції наполягають,
що через зв'язки
з російськими державними концернами
ексканцлера варто внести
до санкційного списку ЄС.
Завтра за це голосуватимуть.
Іноді необхідно уважно аналізувати кожне слово.
У Північному Рейні-Вестфалії Зелені
готові до перемовин з SPD,
а з партією CDU, яка перемогла на виборах,
вони провадитимуть переговори вже сьогодні.
Підтримка Зелених на виборах у Північному
Рейні-Вестфалії минулої неділі зросла майже втричі
порівняно з попередніми виборами, але цього
замало для утворення «червоно-зеленої» коаліції.
Водночас «чорно-зеленої» коаліції в промисловій
землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія ще ніколи не було,
але її можна сміливо назвати
«боротьбою з кліматичною кризою пліч-о-пліч
з боротьбою за економічне зростання
та робочі місця».
До того ж такий союз був би ще одним варіантом
за межами землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія.
А в політиці - що більше варіантів, то краще.
Сюжет Петера Бемера.
Сьогодні вранці багато автомобілістів
хотіли б мати велосипед.
Біля земельного парламенту
на мосту Рейнкні утворився затор.
Інших шляхів немає, адже
Рейнський тунель у місті заблоковано
через технічні проблеми.
Транспортна реформа -
одна з головних тем для Зелених.
Сьогодні відбулося друге засідання нової,
майже втричі більшої, фракційної групи.
«Чорно-зелена» коаліція видніється на обрії,
але поки що представники партій
нічого не згадують про партнерство в коаліції.
З будь-яким потенційним партнером у коаліції
головними темами будуть захист клімату,
транспортна реформа й розбудова енергосистеми
з відновлюваними джерелами.
Це ті теми, на які
ми провадитимемо серйозні переговори.
Я знаю «світлофорну» коаліцію на місцевому рівні,
а також «чорно-зелену» на місцевому рівні.
Побачимо і розмовлятимемо з усіма.
І, звичайно, наша головна мета - втілити те,
за що нас обрали.
Можливі труднощі в співпраці CDU і Зелених -
у питанні розвитку вітроенергетики.
Досі діє норма мінімальної відстані
до житлової забудови 1000 м.
Представники CDU прагнуть її дотримуватися,
Зелені ж хочуть змінити.
Або, наприклад, питання внутрішньої безпеки:
CDU хоче забезпечити поліцію більшою кількістю
нагрудних камер-реєстраторів, електрошокерів
і приладів для відеоспостереження, а Зелені - ні.
Або питання дорожнього руху:
будівництво нових магістралей - за чи проти?
Або перетворення автомобільних смуг у містах
на велосипедні доріжки -
навіть у цьому питанні можливі дискусії.
Але в промисловій політиці, наприклад, є
багато точок перетину:
обидві партії прагнуть
зробити економіку безпечною для клімату.
Обидві громадські партії належать
до «політичної середини»,
тож їх об'єднує багато речей, особливо - прагнення
змінити енергетичну систему,
яку, звісно, передусім підтримують Зелені,
але такою ж мірою це роблять і представники CDU,
якщо це забезпечить робочі місця й буде
організовано з соціальною відповідальністю.
Гіпотетично «світлофорна» коаліція з SPD,
Зеленими й FDP у Дюссельдорфі можлива,
але наскільки це реалістично?
Тристороння коаліція передбачає й поділ
сфери діяльності й інтересів на три.
Навіщо, якщо у двосторонній коаліції Зелені мали б
набагато більше можливостей для реалізації?
Це нелогічно.
Я вважаю це малоймовірним.
А як же Кіль?
Якщо б це залежало від переможця виборів Даніеля Ґюнтера,
то він би утримав позиції «Ямайки» разом із Зеленими та FDP,
хоча також міг би керувати наодинці з будь-яким із них.
Кіль має іншу передісторію.
«Ямайкою» захоплюються
як новим експериментом,
який не тільки спрацював,
але й який виборці прагнуть продовжувати.
Це дуже демократична реакція на успішну модель.
У Дюссельдорфі спочатку все виглядає як двосторонній союз.
По обіді перша розмова
про «оцінку поточної політичної ситуації»,
а потім дві ідентичні заяви.
Це була приємна відверта розмова,
яку ми змогли провести один з одним.
Зараз ми виносимо це на партійні комітети,
щоб обговорити деталі.
Дуже дякую.
Дюссельдорф у постійному русі,
опівдні вдалося ліквідувати затори на мосту Рейнкні.
Побачимо, коли те саме станеться і в парламенті.
«Чорно-зелена» коаліція стала б
поворотним моментом у політиці землі.
Досі немає згоди
щодо покращення умов праці та підвищення зарплати
працівникам соціальної і освітньої сфер.
Муніципальні роботодавці, Об'єднання німецьких профспілок «ver.di»
і Об'єднання держслужбовців dbb
ведуть переговори з понеділка.
Це третій раунд переговорів.
Переговори добігають кінця.
Окрім підвищення зарплати, профспілки вимагають
полегшення умов праці для
приблизно 330 тис. муніципальних працівників.
Кілька тижнів тому президент Росії Путін оголосив,
що російський газ буде доступний лише за рублі.
Однак це порушення санкцій ЄС.
Незабаром Німеччина
повинна також оплатити рахунки за газ,
але виникає питання,
як можна здійснити оплату без порушення санкцій.
Франк Бетман з Франкфурта.
Це буде не так просто, чи не так?
Це дійсно так.
Перед німецькими імпортерами газу
постало непросте завдання.
Їм довелося довго чекати,
поки у ЄС письмово затвердили,
що саме їм тепер дозволено робити, а що - ні.
Після цього, ймовірно,
як у випадку енергетичної компанії «EnBW»
за роботу взялися юристи
і розробили спосіб оплати,
який не порушував би санкцій.
Звісно, ​​бізнес значно ускладнився,
тому що тепер доводиться обробляти платежі
через цілу «конструкцію» рахунків,
оскільки Росія вимагає оплати в рублях.
Простіше кажучи, німецькі енергетичні компанії
продовжать платити в євро або доларах.
Російський «Газпромбанк»,
який не підпадає під санкції, обмінюватиме їх на рублі.
Але диявол криється в деталях.
З точки зору Брюсселю,
оплата повинна здійснюватися в
євро або доларах - як це передбачено в договорі.
Відкриття рахунку в рублях
було б явним порушенням санкцій
з боку німецьких постачальників.
Завдяки розробленій системі
поки що рішення знайдено.
Але все ж залишається деяка невизначеність.
Голова «EnBW» Франк Мастьйо сьогодні заявив:
«Побачимо, чи це спрацює в довгостроковій перспективі».
Велика непевність панує сьогодні і в Нью-Йорку.
Через побоювання інвесторів щодо підвищення відсоткових ставок
Федеральною резервною системою
індекс Dow Jones втратив 3.5%.
Дякую, Франк, за детальну інформацію.
Французька компанія з виробництва сталевих труб «Vallourec»
повідомила про закриття 2 заводів в
Дюссельдорфі та Мюльгаймі-на-Рурі
до кінця 2023 року.
У компанії повідомили,
що близько 2400 співробітників будуть звільнені.
«Vallourec» виробляє
безшовні сталеві труби для нафтогазового ринку.
За 7 років в Німеччині компанія
зазнала значних збитків.
На черзі лотерея.
Номери лотереї на екрані.
Всі дані, як завжди, без гарантій.
Рідко можна побачити музей
в такому оточенні, як той, який подарували Берліну.
Навколо - наркоторгівля, проституція, надземна залізниця.
Всередині – картини тендітного суспільства, що руйнується.
Зовні - двадцяті років нашого століття.
Всередині - двадцяті роки минулого століття,
які зараз видаються шокуюче актуальними.
Берлінський колекціонер встановив пам'ятник
своєму улюбленому художнику Ґеорґу Ґроссу.
Вражаюче місце, присвячене тому,
хто з самого початку застерігав
від жахіть націонал-соціалізму та війни
і чиє мистецтво давно
не було настільки актуальним, як зараз.
Крістхард Леппле проведе нам екскурсію.
Мрія стає реальністю.
92-річна американка німецького походження
може знову пережити цей момент.
Картини її тестя Ґеорґа Ґросса
в новому приватному музеї у Берліні.
Це фантастично.
Картини в місті,
яке 90 років тому виштовхало і вигнало його.
Ліліан Ґросс з Прінстона повернулася до рідної Німеччини,
щоб відсвяткувати велике повернення
в маленькому музеї Ґеорґа Ґросса.
Музей у переобладнаній заправній станції?
Я знаю.
Це правильно -  музей Ґросса в колишній заправці?
Все якраз правильно!
З любов’ю переобладнана заправна станція 1956 року
розташована біля надземної залізниці
на вулиці Bülowstraße.
Квартал навколо площі Ноллендорф,
де молодий Ґеорґ Ґросс пережив
неспокійні роки Веймарської республіки.
«Стовпи суспільства» - різка критика «золотих» двадцятих,
які були золотими лише для небагатьох.
Його знаменитій картині «Танець на вулкані»
виповнилось майже 100 років.
Ґросс - влучний літописець та
ілюстратор книги «Вавилон-Берлін».
Я б сказав, що Ґеорґа Ґросса можна вважати
одним із найважливіших художників 20 століття.
Він завжди боровся
проти багатих та пихатих людей.
Він завжди виступав за «маленьку» людину.
Він завжди був таким.
Як «маленька» людина
Ґеорґ Еренфрід Ґросс - таке його повне ім'я -
малював усе, що його цікавило.
«Жаби».
Перші спроби в одинадцятирічному віці.
Ранні картини художника можна побачити вперше.
Син шинкаря малював жахи Першої світової війни
і попереджав у 1920-ті роки
про наближення Другої світової війни.
Ґросс з самого початку був противником Гітлера.
Ще в 1923 році він намалював його як Зіґфріда,
який веде свій народ до загибелі.
Його можна охарактеризувати як заклятого
непримиренного ворога Гітлера,
оскільки він був одним із перших,
хто публічно висловлювався проти Гітлера.
В той час, коли Гітлер був популярним
у пивних Мюнхену
і коли люди в Берліні, особливо художники,
взагалі ним не цікавилися.
Що змінилося сьогодні, у наші двадцяті?
Це ядро завжди лишається: бунтарі і революціонери,
але зараз живуть, говорять і
усвідомлюють все зовсім по-іншому.
У 1933 році Ґросс втік до США.
Про нього забули.
Він пив, страждав від депресії.
Лише в 1959 році Ґросс повернувся і помер у рідному місті.
«Діра художника» -
його остання картина.
Для Ліліан Ґросс його повернення - щасливий випадок.
До речі, як і для нас.
Випуск «auslandsjournal» перенесе нас до міста,
яке знаходиться на межі надії та страху:
до Харкова, де люди й досі живуть у шахтах метро,
а інші ризикують життям,
щоб забезпечити продуктами харчуванням своїх співгромадян.
Близько 00:30 наш «heute journal up:date»
з Назан Гьокдемір.
Добрий вечір.
Сьогодні в Німеччині було дуже спекотно,
а зараз наближається гроза,
яка завтра ввечері досягне Швеції.
Сьогодні ввечері - без опадів,
переважно ясно.
У великих містах Рурського регіону
температура не нижче 20°.
Вночі в Баварії прохолодно -
від 10° до 8° .
Завтра буде набагато гарячіше -
від 26° до 31°.
Тільки на Північному морі прохолодніше.
Вже завтра вранці в Емсленді
очікується гроза.
На інших територіях - сонячно.
Потім стане справді спекотно.
Вдень у Саарі та Рейнланд-Пфальці,
Північному Рейні-Вестфалії,
на заході Нижньої Саксонії
пройдуть сильні грози.
Ввечері також в Шварцвальді та Альпах.
Будьте готові до шторму
з поривами вітру до 100 км/год та
з сильним дощем до 40 літрів на квадратний метр
і з градом
діаметром 3 см.
У п’ятницю ввечері грози припиняться.
Але це ще не все,
адже вже в п’ятницю наближається наступний циклон.
До ранку суботи він пошириться
по всій центральній та північній Німеччині.
Можуть бути ще сильніші грози, ніж завтра.
Очікується великий град.
І лише в неділю погода покращиться.
Гарного вечора.